hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are unboxing it to Lemieux and
have to watch Series three these are
actually the Apple watch Series three
Edition which means they are ceramic I
got the new gray ceramic and the new
white ceramic that is where the dilemma
comes in which one do you like more and
which one do you think that is more
fitting for me because I'm unsure the
fate of which watch I keep is in your
hands as you see there's two different
colored logos here this one is the
silver and this is a little bit more of
a gray color pretty safe to assume that
the color logo represents what color
watch is in the box I'm gonna do two
unboxing this at the same time take two
oh man I hope you guys are ready for
this because I'm not sure if I am
I don't see anything yet
[Music]
Wow
okay Wow see everything just came out
all at once ever seen those people boxes
oh well if you have it you're not gonna
see it here today
first things first at each box we've got
our power bricks as usual next up we've
got our Lightning kit oh wait wait whoa
hold on a second
except two cables here there is they
have one lightning cable in one Apple
watch cable also included in the Edition
or these Apple watch base chargers which
are awesome these just pop right up and
you can plug in a lightning cable right
to the back of them set your Apple watch
down and charge these are great
synchronized unboxings here they are
here's a problem that I've already
noticed well no I hope that if I decide
to keep the wet one because it looks
like the BAM they have on it is one of
the medium large ones do not throw this
extra piece of a Pilar right this smells
like fried chicken
so I smells really good enough I need
lunch inside if you hear a guy is one of
the small/medium bands so if you do need
the smaller band do not throw this away
it is included inside here let's take
them out and take a look smaller watch
face it's very enticing to me I got the
black 38 and being white 42 because I
have the 42 already and I really like it
I do have some reservations sometimes
because it's a very big watch base it's
also gonna look exactly like the same
one that I already have is this a bigger
watch face it's a face bigger no it's
exactly the same I love this watch band
inside of it is a nice little gray color
this is very different from any of the
other bands which I like another nice
little touch is this one does have the
little ceramic button here which you
just attach like so so that's nice I was
always a little bit confused as to why
they decided to go with the silicon
bands because they're probably the least
expensive ones to make and these ceramic
edition watches are very very very very
very expensive
for essentially the same functionality
as all the other washes the biggest
difference with the ceramic is it is way
more durable it's also a little bit
heavier so if you're looking for
something very very light and we
definitely go with an aluminum it's also
way less expensive and here's the new
gray ceramic this looks really good I
love this dark grey band so the issue is
I think that I'm gonna be getting the
white iPhone 10 wow the small one
actually looks kinda nice what do I do
oh boy this is really nice actually I
mean do I need a bigger screen does this
look better on me I was definitely
dissing but it doesn't really bother me
that much is to be completely honest
with you I'm probably never really gonna
see it I mean most of the time I'm gonna
be looking at my phone from this angle
does either a dot but I did find
something that you can use to cover the
red dot so I'll be showing you guys that
as soon as I get that in for the time
being I think I might like the 38 no I
think I like the white there I can't go
back to a 38 do you know why let me tell
you why I have invested a lot of money
into Apple watch bands and they're all
442 well I guess that makes my decision
very easy why did I buy a 38 cuz now I
was a 38 this can't happen I can't that
can't I can't have that this 38 feels
really large I like the smaller watch
face I think I've made a mistake for the
past several years who that I've had an
Apple watch
what am I done I just can't believe how
much bigger the 42 is and this is like
three years into owning an Apple watch
and I'm just now realizing that I
probably should have got the smaller one
so here's the white ceramic which it
looks almost identical to the previous
Apple watch to version so there's really
not much of a difference other than of
course this red dot so if you're
completely confused as to what those red
dots signify that means that these
watches are LTE enabled and what that
means you can use your watch as a phone
you can leave your phone at home if you
need to go to walk the dog or you can't
have access to your phone you can send
messages you can get notifications you
can basically do almost everything that
you would normally do on your phone now
on your little watch of course my
biggest concern with having an LTE and
abled watch is that battery life I've
yet to be able to test that out so I
will definitely let you guys know when I
do a full review of this little guy
because I've been using an Apple watch
since the very first one
are you ready come and get it no no no
no and at this point I've become so used
to having it that I do rely a lot on it
so my big concern is number one I'm
gonna start to rely way too much on the
LTE and less on my phone which may drain
the battery more than my previous
version so I don't know we're gonna find
all of that out very
soon one of the biggest concerns that
I've heard from a lot of people is that
the crystal on the back is bigger if I'm
kind of just eyeballing this I mean you
can sort of very vaguely tell that it's
slightly more raised oh this matches my
knife hmm
okay so two pieces of paper I'm
wondering what cardstock that paper is
because it's clearly not a printer paper
bring iPhone your Apple watch I'm really
liking this new set up oh just bring
your item nearby and it'll start setting
up restore from backup I will restore it
from my previous phone and here we go it
is now connecting to my beautiful gold
iPhone aids I can't even tell you guys
how excited I am about everything that's
going on right now like the world that
we live in is crazy the rate in which
technology changes in advances is
unbelievable like the things that we
think that we know that are happening
now it's really nothing that we can
imagine years from now I am so excited
for you kids that are very young because
I'm sure I won't be around to see some
of the insane things that are happening
maybe I will maybe I will freeze my body
and my body will be unfrozen many many
years from now and I would be like wow I
don't remember how to edit anymore
anyway the new watch I said this in
another video but I'm sure there's gonna
be questions for people who may have not
seen it the reason that I wear my watch
on this arm is because I'm left-handed
so normally people do that gives you
right with your left hand and you don't
want to be like knocking your watch
everywhere while you're trying to write
I think it looks good I mean I love the
white ceramic original one so this looks
great although I'm probably gonna switch
to this pink sand band because it looks
really good well it's definitely a good
look you know I really like the smaller
watch face a lot you guys might want to
consider that when purchasing if you
have a small wrist because I think I'm
stuck with the big one because I've got
so many watch bands that I can't bring
myself to never be able to use those
again am I supposed to be doing
something or is this setting itself up
so I was running into some care of your
issues trying to set up cellular and I'm
not really sure what the issue was but I
didn't feel like dealing with it anymore
so now I'm just sinking everything so
here it is it is setting up currently
but I am pretty excited about the new
watch and I look forward to testing out
some of the new fitness features which
is going to hopefully motivate me to
you get my butt to the gym and working
out a little bit more who knows maybe
next year I can be the one to write him
a letter and say yo Tim I finally went
back to the gym B Siri remind me to go
to the gym every day that was my old
phone that I had set up because I don't
have a serious setup on here yet anyway
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know which watch face you prefer if
you guys have a favorite do you have an
Apple watch are you going to get one are
you not going to get more why why not do
you think the cellular is a little bit
over the top do you think it's something
that you would use do not want to pay
the extra monthly fee will I use the LTE
enough on this Apple watch to really
justify paying ten dollars a month
I'm not sure I am just very very upset
about this whole size dilemma like I
don't understand I think that I was
gonna be watching full feature films on
my wrist that I would need this extra
large screen for my extremely small
wrist like my wrists are very small like
I can't even do push-ups because I think
my wrists are gonna like crack all right
I'll see you guys later
I gotta go edit this video now I like
the smaller watch base
[Music]